buongiorno
io sono bar
coordina sono un ricercatore
dell'università di palermo
oggi vi porto l'esperienza di cody cody
è una tecnica di produzione di tessuto
cartilagineo umano prodotto utilizzando
il coniglio questa tecnica ha ottenuto
l'anno scorso un brevetto italiano
rilasciato dal ministero dello sviluppo
economico e cody sta per il nome degli
inventori che sono io
corradino e di lorenzo di per di lorenzo
vi assicuro che passare quattro anni
laboratorio per portare alla fine questa
ricerca è stato veramente pazzo e
faticoso perché faccio chirurgo e vivo
di sala operatoria e abbandona il lavoro
per dedicarsi alla ricerca un ex è
facilissimo ma alla fine dopo 4 anni e 3
anni di attesa per espletare la
procedura per letta è stato veramente
difficile ma la fia siamo molto contenti
perché siamo gli unici al mondo che
riusciva a produrre tessuto cartilagineo
solido io faccio il chirurgo plastico mi
occupo di ave un rapporto diretto con i
pazienti
mi sono sempre occupato di oncologia di
malformazioni di chirurgia ricostruttiva
al seno il tumore al seno una patologia
che ormai di cui si guarisce e quando la
paziente a cui viene diagnosticato un
tumore al seno si presenta la nostra
osservazione una paziente che ormai è
molto distrutta non ha voglia di vivere
il dialogo col chirurgo serve ma serve
per cambiamo la prospettiva alla
malattia
noi offriamo alla paziente tutto quello
che possiamo offrire sia dal campo di
costruttivo ma su tutto dal punto di
vista del campo dell'estetica offriamo
le tecniche ed estetiche per ricostruire
a dare una nuova vita un nuovo sorriso
alla paziente la paziente sul velo
intervento di mastectomia e noi gli
offriamo la possibilità di aver
ricostruito un seno ma anche rimodellare
il seno controlaterale questo alla fine
del calvario gli darà la possibilità di
avere una nuova vita con l'uomo sorriso
questa è un'opzione che a tutte le donne
ha offerto è impossibile che ancora nel
2018 alcuni pazienti le donne vengono
operate di mastectomia e non si offre la
possibilità di avere una ricostruzione
mammaria vi dicevo il chirurgo si occupa
di ricostruzione questo un tumore della
della pal perché è stato asportato per
ricostruirle utilizziamo dei tessuti di
vicinanze poi ci abbiamo bisogno per
questo
la palpebra di cartilagine la cartina in
questo caso viene prelevata dal setto
nasale
ma la cosa più importante quando ci
troviamo i pazienti che hanno una
malformazione del padiglione auricolare
nascono con la micro zia c'e l'assenza
completa della cartilagine
non abbiamo bisogno di prelevare tessuto
cartilagineo solido a livello postale di
andare allo sterno aprire lo sterno
selezionare la sesta e la settima
cartilagine la banca di piantarla
la tecnica cody nasce proprio da con
questa esigenza evitare di fare
cicatrici in più e avere tessuto utile
per la ricostruzione tutto il mondo si
occupa di ritrovare di sviluppare ed è
che le rivoluzioni tessuto ma tutti
partono un concetto iniziale partono
tutti dalle cellule staminali le cellule
staminali vengono prelevati o dal sangue
da te sto riposo o dal mito all'osso
vengono differenziati in cellule che poi
potranno tessuto specifico il mio tipo
basta muscolo lo stop l'astruso rosso e
chi contro i controlli ci devono
cartilagini questo lavorato questo un
lavoro che devono fare i biologi vi
faccio il plastico sull'abito da risolve
il problema nel minor tempo possibile
la cosa più semplice che mi è venuta
l'idea è quella di utilizzare tutto
quello che c'era in commercio abbiamo
preso una sospensione di cellule contro
l'italia si trovano in commercio
l'abbiamo messo il laboratorio abbiamo
stimolate l'abbiamo impiantate su uno
scafo di acido ialuronico
lo scafo lo abbiamo impiantato sul dorso
del coniglio e dopo cinque mesi abbiamo
tenuto cartilagine solida da una cellula
a guttuso tessuto solito siamo gli unici
al mondo
questa cartilagine nel corpo ma nel
ricco di cartilagine
la cartina g è un tessuto ricchissimo di
acqua viaggio ironico fibroblasti si
separano 2 comprende una parte fluido la
parte solida la parte fluida né dalla
società la parte solida la resistenza
esistono a fare una grande cartilagine
gli all in e che quella che noi ricopri
ca particolari ma la troviamo anche sul
naso a carte l'agefi plauso e quello dei
menischi sia vertebrale che quella del
ginocchio e poi abbiamo la cartilagine
elastica quella che tutti chiamano
livello del padiglione auricolare e
delle piloti di quello che abbiamo
quello che siamo riusciti a produrre
laboratori e una cartilagine matura che
dal punto di vista della keller
umana il ris di messina ci hanno
certificato che quel tessuto ricreato e
costruite laboratorio utilizzando il
vostro amico coniglio coniglio viene
addormentato coccolato cresciuto
riaddormentato praticamente stato ma
rimane viva fa la sua vita non è l'unico
mezzo che utilizziamo e per un tessuto
non capiamo nessun danno anno fa amico e
tessuto umano certificato questo tipo di
cartilagine possiamo tranquillamente
utilizzata anche per produrre il l
tracheali per la chirurgia toracica
dicevo quello che otteniamo e tessuto
solido simile alla cartilagine al
padiglione auricolare uscita la notizia
di cody sui giornali e su facebook
siamo stati perseguitati telefonate di
gente cardona giorgio i giovani agli
anziani su tutte giorno che fanno
attività fisica
l'articolazione si usura ica particolare
della del ginocchio la tbf non solo le
coperte da cartilagine la cartilagine
galina sono cellule non è una
cartilagine solida con l'usura questa
cartilagine si assottiglia
assottigliando non si rigenera perché la
cartilagine unico tessuto che non ha
basi capillari in the in suoi e si nutre
per diffusione quando c'è un tramontano
che riguarda la cartina jakarta gelo non
si rigenera la possiamo solo sostituire
dicevo sia i giovani atleti o gli
anziani che soffro di un processo di
degenerazione della cartilagine che
porta alla trosi questi casi il chi ci
chiedevano ha finalmente avete avete
inventato la tecnica per risolve il mio
problema oggi no anche noi facciamo
altro io faccio il plastico il mio
occupo di pezzi di ricambio
in questi casi molte volte si posso si
può utilizzare la cartilagine quelle in
sospensione che noi abbiamo utilizzato
per la nostra ricerca e si può inventare
ma nelle forme più gravi
ricordate che ha l'unico rimedio solo le
protesi c'è bisogna completamente
cambiare i due segmenti articolari
perché la cartilagine viene meno
l'osso si strofina e creatrice crea
dolore
dicevo la nostra cartilagine un altro
che un tessuto da poter utilizzare per
l'innesto non lo utilizzano in chirurgia
plastica per il naso per i costi dei
nasi per costruire per esempio
padiglioni auricolari
ma la cosa più bella in assoluto della
ricerca che noi
abbiamo messo in atto no la cartilagine
ma noi abbiamo brevettato un processo di
produzione di tessuto questo significa
che ogni paziente che abbia bisogno per
una malattia xd cartilagine di pezzi di
cambio noi possiamo produrre la sua
cartilagine
il kit si prevede di prelevare un po di
cartilagine di contro ci dal
dall'orecchio la facciamo crescere
laboratorio line pianta ma nel nostro
scafo questo scafo dopo le cellule
coltivate viene impiantato a livello
dell'avambraccio e possiamo ottenere
dopo 90 giorni perduto della forma delle
zone che vogliamo
ognuno di noi si produce tessuto di un
ricambio quando un paziente è in sicilia
purtroppo è una patologia molto
frequente ci sono il tumore che
riguardano la cute il tumore sono le
zone silenti lentissime che insorgono e
piccolissime lesioni e poi piano piano
degenera e vanno a infiltrare se
presente se interessa la punta del naso
sia la cute la cartilagine e la mucosa e
quando mina la nostra osservazione
dobbiamo poi ricostruire
abbiamo bisogno di cute di cartilagine e
di mucosa per ricostruire la cartilagine
possiamo utilizzare nella nostra
cartilagine di base vi voglio raccontare
la storia che è successo un anno e mezzo
fa quando la mia osservazione si
presenta un signore di 65 anni con un
morso che gli hanno causato
l'amputazione traumatica della punta del
naso quasi completa nella mia esperienza
una cosa frequente avere una mutazione
da morso voi penserete sicuramente un
morso da animale nella mia esperienza ho
trattato morsi di coniglio di dopo di
cavallo disguido o di cinghiale delle
madonie
ma questo signor ha subito un trauma da
morso da uomo era stato aggredito in
macchina questo signore era aveva
amputato naso una parte la aveva
digerito da una parte la vas quotata e
per ricostruire questo cartilagine
questa punta del naso in maniera
tridimensionale
abbiamo dovuto smontare moretti a
cosiddetto prelevare la cartilagine e
ricostruire la punta del naso e dopo vi
fosse sicura dopo tre mesi il paziente
tornato alla sua vita
male a questo punto facciamo una
cicatrice sul viso una ciclica
sull'orecchio cody ci avrebbe dato la
possibilità di ricostruire il tessuto
senza cicatrici alternative
la cosa che mi piace di più io mi occupo
di chirurgia ricostruttiva ma ha saputo
di estetica
faccio il plastico la cartilagine si può
utilizzare in chirurgia estetica in
quell'intervento nella rinoplastica il
naso ed identifica una etnia
noi abbiamo un naso mediterraneo un naso
anglosassone un naso greco un africano
uno medio orientale è un orientale
il nostro naso italiano il naso classico
proiettato con piccolo cibo con la punta
cadente con la pelle molto classe il
naso invece anglosassone è un naso con
cut è molto sottile la punta iper
proiettata tutti conosciamo il naso
africano punte gommosi importanti con la
pelle molto grassi ma noi interessa
questo tipo di naso le donne orientali
che hanno un naso molto piccolo e in
senato per loro il cane co di bellezza
per eccellenza e avere un naso che
somigli alle nostre donne europee
noi siamo fortunati poi ce lo vogliono
picco e sollevato e quale migliore
tecnica per sollevare il naso non è
quello di utilizzare cartilagine allo in
questi casi per un intervento di
estetica bisogna modellare preleva la
cartilagine dell'orecchio in maniera da
dare una proiezione che noi possiamo
offrire a queste pazienti
un intervento che diventa mininvasivo si
può fare sia locale e risolvere il loro
problema
la popolazione cinese e sulla
popolazione cinese sono tre miliardi di
persone di cui 56 milioni sono i veri
ricchi a me come ricercatore basta
solamente che il 3 per cento dei
chirurghi plastici utilizza la mia te
che per farmi cambiare lavoro e perché
voglio dire se credete a mia figlia che
lavora fa papa vedra tranquillamente che
papa fa il medico il chirurgo lo
scienziato basi tutte falegname che fa
bricolage
grazie
[Applauso]